en matière de musique les enfants ont
toujours un goût sûr ils ont
instantanément apprécié la fanfare du
Bénin ambiance garantie avec ce groupe
en tournée à la Réunion obligation de
bouger
[Musique]
on a appris comment ça s'appelait enfin
différents instruments on les a vu jouer
aussi ils ont présenté les instruments
en musique ils nous ont dit d'où il
venait et
nous avons appris plein de trucs
[Musique]
ils ont plein d'instruments qui fait
danser qui fait bouger et quand tu te
mets debout ça donne directement envie
de danser et tout
[Musique]
les instruments étaient trop cool ça
nous donnait envie de danser les
instruments j'en fais un produit une
jolie
les enfants du centre d'action sociale
ont en effet eu droit à une instruction
captivante délivrée avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmes par les musiciens normal
quand on s'appelle eyonne-les c'est
vous en anglais
donc nous sommes venus pour la mission
de faire de réjouir les gens c'est une
musique qui est conçue exprès pour
pour faire la fête il y a aussi des
concerts il y a aussi des rencontres de
fanfare il y a de la déambulation on va
pas passer inaperçu
régulièrement invité en Europe dans
divers festivals populaires la fanfare
jouera ce soir dans les quartiers du
port et ce jeudi entre autres au théâtre
sous les arbres
[Musique]